le monde s'excuse et on se rend
aujourd'hui en compagnie de poussins tu
as à savoir mezzo sur minecraft alors
ouais ça fait très longtemps que pas
fait de vieux os sur minecraft est
aujourd'hui c'est une map assez fun tu
peux revenir en mode normal go puisque
au maire daniel tombe puisque oui
attendez on va juste faire un petit truc
est ce qu'on peut mettre des voix la
wizo mais ce que oui on est dans un parc
d'attractions et c'est pas classe
franchement ça a l'air juste énormissime
alors on va y aller direct juste j'avais
commencé la map j'étais allée juste là
là là là où il ya ma souris vous voyez
juste larmes donc c'était s'était jamais
arrivé j'ai juste fait la pêche aux
canards
apparemment on a des instructions pour
une énigme attend que cet indice fusion
le 1er rajhi s'est elle est en bois
d'accord à 100 avec le bouton rentrer
dans le match car tu es mal on votre jeu
rame t-il non ouais commencé trop stylé
alors le mont mapaq je sais plus et
lequel d'ailleurs mais ils étaient
mignons elle était plutôt mignon tu me
suis ouais ça vole un peu moins c'est
bon c'est très coloré vous voyez ouais
moi aussi ça rame un peu j'ai un peu le
sommes d'ailleurs d'avoir mis non j'aime
pas alors qu'au final il m'a vanté
graphique billetterie bonjour je me suis
habillé pour pour ça l'arn y a rien
dedans annonce au nom ya rien n'y a rien
dans ce cas rentrait non on va braquer
le parc
voilà à temps il ya quoi là dedans golf
golf aux milices locales à temps
il ya des entend un peu j'en ai pris
c'est vraiment une autre fois t'es où je
suis là bon mois ci mais il regarde vous
faut les viser le trou a tancé par du
golfe c'est de l'arnaqué
je promets rien qu'ils sont bien passés
mais presque oui bon allez on se casse
c'est pourri au j'ai réussi bravo
[Rires]
appuyer sur un bouton de sur un de ces
boutons pour le soleil mois
il y avait déjà le soigner en fait mais
ouais sens interdits pêche aux canards
voilà c'est ça que j'avais fait il faut
pas là dessus at on pas les tigres matin
gervais et comment on enlève le fils je
sais pas va sur le garde assez bon
rapproché attendant je vais revenir vers
moi de faire moi tiens je vais te
sucreries aux parents et à de la prison
mais c'est pourquoi je vous défie
annonce ce qui m'a tapé dix ans son
cadet hugo combien la pression c'est
celle que j'avais fait je m'étais
arrêtée là alors hier comme assez bien
foutu suit le chemin d'un patronat parce
que peter la demande un truc orange ça
va ça va t'aider pas entre hugo non non
non c'est dallas à mercredi
ok alors à des gis membres attend récit
va y envoyer leurs brevets non c'est
plutôt en dedans dans le mind de cartes
il veut de moi et vous voilà avec lui tu
avances quasi exhaustive mais il veut
pas me monde attend mais bouge mais
c'est quoi ce bug mais bougez d'égal
l'espagne a réussi - il veut que je veux
pas que j'y aille mais toujours à côté
de moi à savon c'est quoi cette
infraction à ça c'est l'attraction
number one
[Rires]
elle va pas faire ça tout le temps quand
même
je suis ok je finis à temps d'arrêt à
temps je te paie je te rattraper que ma
canne à pêche
merde [ __ ] j'ai rampé lui prend un cap
ces vases et on continue boissons ah
ouais grave ou des potions c'est quoi ça
sert à quoi
c'est des potions voila voila voila tu
en as tu m'as piqué la mienne
là il fait un gros bruit genre moi j'ai
laquelle gros c'est quoi il mais nous ça
ah non pardon place et bien on continue
notre chemin
c'est quoi ça tour de feu ou et
instruction se met proche du bouton
appuyer dessus at en recul ne plus
toucher aux commandes c'est votre pc lag
l'ascenseur lag dans ce cas plaqué vous
contre un bouton appuyer dessus a qui
vont être un bouton l'ascenseur qui
évalue votre level de lag
olalala beh je sais qu'ils ont là nous
quitter sheila attends je crois de fou
non c'est quoi c'est quoi et je sais pas
monte et la tentative de moins mais
selon déjà rien compris mais où est ce
qu'on va aller un bouton la phase i ok
appui et ça m'a poussé à céder push
appuyé chaque fois sur les boutons c'est
des pistons qui te pousse toi ça te
pousse ça fait quoi passer pour monter
en fait parce que mon cabinet pistons
alors tu appuies attend il ya un truc
que je veuille calais de la vidéo tend à
être dégueulasse c'est que j'adore les
gens aimeront entendant double en fait
pourquoi parce que ya le son de deux
tests et elles sont de deux frappes ce
au nom bon âge et j'essaierai de biens
superposés alors si tu prouves étape
enlevée
fraps je peux pas j'ai obligé
d'enregistrer le son manque un peu tu
peux enlever le son de frappe juste les
vois comment je fais ah non non non j'ai
rien dit voilà je préfère bon alors
attends tour d'autour de feu qu'est ce
qu'on fait car bien écrit à une manette
vas-y vas-y ton parcours moi je vis ici
abba terme de mon truc vas-y moi je fais
le ligoter alors je fais l'autre côté
moi je prends l'eau moi je suis je prêt
que toi je fais partie cousin drago feu
alors attends qu en fait faut faire quoi
faut appuyer sur le levier non ben moi
j'ai avancé puis ça m'a sont annoncés hu
j'avais même pas plus qu'avec blizzard
ne pourront rien je coupe
au gabon
alors cette attraction merde merde on se
perd du temps sur ce match alors ce
connard bons fous pour la peine je bois
alors je n'ai firewall ruée vers l'or
aire de jeu alors il n'y a pas un truc à
faire au sein au [ __ ] il ya trop vite
je veux le faire je veux le faire je
veux le faire c'est la rieuse c'est sur
cela c'est là à temps
j'ai vraiment promis merde à t elle été
long pourquoi je peux pas l'aider
donc cette cure pourquoi je peux pas
aller dedans et parce que si c'est bon
j'imagine hired talus mauvais coup tu as
été houleux je suis en dessous obtient
salle monte oh non légaux je repars
quand j'arrive là je suis coincé dans le
truck
non j'étais à temps je suis dans le
mauvais sens je suis dans le mauvais
sens c'est par là c'est par là allez y
as oui avatar a réussi à temps j'arrive
au lavage
mais comment ça monte météo là comment
ça descend mais dégage mais pourquoi tu
apparais devant moi des fois comme ça
mais je suis pas c'est deadline oise et
j'y vais ça monte à san bruno fond ouah
ça monte tellement on a travaillé mais
qu en bas tu veux quoi à mon pc il a
accès
au nom du racisme mais comment s'en
veulent oui
oh [ __ ] je brûle bloqué mais on est
bloqué à cause de ton man car tu avais
descendre assez bon je suis en train de
brûler hugo mais une majorité d'états
j'ai fait la queue leu leu d'emine carte
c'était magnifique
attention je sonne moi j'ai une pomme
parce que quand il a battu moi je veux
qu'on me donne rien ah je suis con c'est
plus comme ça maintenant si les cuisses
il est cuit ouais boys et les cuisses
comment tu coures j'arrive pas à courir
deux fois la flèche de haut enfin deux
fois ok computer mais ces immenses quoi
servir mais je regarde ça c'est quoi si
les trucs avec les chevaux de quoi et
les manèges au match nul elle a l'air
énorme là haut à gauche
le manager avec les chevaux métiers où
il ya des fous qui tourne souffler ses
mannequins bombe
ah oui attention quand le pop longo
[ __ ] c'est trop je suis ton à la
soirée
oméga 6
j'aimerais j'en ai marre j'ai par une
approche critique des stages et des
cultes rapporte et perdu là bas bien
mais t'as qu'à baisser le son du jeu
ouais c'est ce que je vais faire alors
musique 0% alors qu'est ce qu'on fait à
bas salaires
le truc rouge oh c'est pas la tour de la
terreur là bas ça c'est là on a commencé
je crois ou meurs c'est pas là on a
commencé en fait tout simplement temps
le voir c'est peut-être ça et un passage
devant et c'est peut-être ça un an noncé
passera ses palettes aux donateurs
attend ça se trouve il y avait peut-être
un train fantôme mec non ruines poteaux
invasion du koweit et passe au dessus
des barrières on y va on y va
placez vous sur le cube visé le kart en
haut rang spam crête endroit oh [ __ ]
et après un quasi forcée pas mais le
clic droit
oui ça monte ouais ça monte à la
chapelle rue dans le jo il ya un bug non
non je suis dit [ __ ] foire et je me
retrouve en up hutin sortie en à
couillet attend de seconde sortie tu
fais couillet la vache attaque ya un bac
technique dans le jeu à temps j'arrive à
ton avis je fais des centres rapide et
dangereuse de piquetage apparaît dans de
l'eau bordel mais pourquoi tu as pleuré
dans le blu ces jeux c'est ben je peux
me tp sur toi bats essaye de faire cela
tp poussins ceinture assez bon je la
regarde sorti en avançant oh [ __ ] gt
ou alors la sortie dangereuse vous fait
quoi c'est au sortir de l'audience et où
ses salles à dessein pirates dont
généreuse et l'autre c'est quoi l'autre
celle en bas on va faire un nom c'est
plus rigolo battant banon lens et paris
vont bien mais c'est exact à quoi tu en
viens devant pour déçus at fort recul
[Musique]
où est elle on aurait dit une vieille
chiasse de pigeons un matériau rotman
mais oui mais mettez trop bas mais t'es
trop stylé battant ça on va aux
bouteilles a pas un train fantôme et des
fous comment tu fais un train fantôme
sur mech mec jusqu'en turquie un train
fantôme c'est pas possible je dis gamin
c'est la xsara gains peu grâce à la
gouache veut dire qu'il ya tellement de
trucs assez impressionnant quoi taille
un noir dix huit ans dans le crash
aurait plus dit non non attends au viala
l'oeil d'horus instruction sauce un
petit comme verdun grille et laissez
votre ami profiter d'une vue plus
éloignés ou bien lancé un kart vide
éloignez-vous vas-y hugo va dedans
rigaux je suis wave asie vas-y vas-y tu
vas me lancer dans la vie avance allait
alors qu'est ce tu vas aller page montre
ouais bon je monte encore
ouais c'est pourtant au genre descends
tu fais rire de temps et je remonte à à
ses deux garçons boucle attends je vais
le faire on va voir la vue qui à la
hausse
ja oui mais tu m'as kony et l'as maya le
médiateur givet [ __ ] t'es lourd à
tanger voilà en fait tout là haut on
descend on descend pour voir là dessus
howie [ __ ] tu vas tu vas tu perds tes
parents guen et en quatorze éditions on
peut voir les attractions où sa bague de
là on est on peut voir les attractions
le truc en valeur ma poche tu vois le
truc en face on l'a fait là ou pas
maintenant le truc vert on n'a pas fait
il ya dix ans par l'eau est tellement
mille assez bon alors ouais ouais là ne
voit pas la lune tour fantôme énigme aux
mecs quand tu mets ton curseur sur
l'attraction il ya le vieux à nos
jardins
je suis un battant je me tapais sur toi
c'est un plus vite et devient un nouvel
an bonjour les meilleurs albums regard
est maire la monuc va t on y va on y va
allons échouer aux tests du marabout
alors code pour entrer code que vous
rentrez rentrez votre app hutin c'est
l'attraction secrète je crois attente on
va voir au [ __ ] 1 19 6 13
ah ouais non mais c'est l'attraction
secrète faut qu'on trouve un truc en
bois c'est marqué dans le livre des
énigmes ou est le premier indice elle
est en bois est en bois balkans bois je
passais vient ce je sais c'est quoi
c'est quoi et la traction avec des
attentats et du tir à l'arc
oh non j'ai tiré le pnj appuyé sur le
bouton pour un nouveau pnj attends je
vais tester tir à l'arc ou tue des
phoques dessus et c'est comme ça les
deux fautes défensives mais ya pas de
mec à temps
merde plus tard garde mais quand chea
pnj regarde hop on va faire cependant
pnj ah bon non il a enlevé les créatures
donc bugge de pnj america a tant pis bon
bah tant pis pas de tir à l'arc à temps
j'ai vu un pnj
mais qu un coup ah oui sa tâche il m'a
sorti fétiche est il va sortir un one
shot le mec et jean normal quoi allez
salut pour la mit alors à temps en gare
d'avignon d'un accroc cuba raconte hub
goce acronyme attend qu'un petit une
petite rivière navigable 10 ans va bien
on vient là vient la voir faire une
balade en entrant tram-train moore vient
quelque peu aleris et voilà il ya des
bateaux ono barka ba oui oh bah oui les
allez on y va aller a cédé dégage mc
ouvrent des foies gras ya des salles bug
je te vois à côté de moi quand tu pars
sur ton truc moi mais pourtant je suis
loin ou [ __ ] c'est galère a tourné au
[ __ ] j'ai péter moor j'ai dit ouais
bah ouais venir avec moi pendant mon
amour tu es si mignon tu me prêtes on
bateau non je viens taylor non je vais
dans la crau club c'est quoi sa loterie
100% aléatoire récupérer les terres on
ne préside pas de le bouton texas
loterie on y va moi je dis ne passe par
nos moutons que personne ne vous tombez
dit oh la vache c'est quoi ça dans
arrête arrête arrête alors fait boutons
fonctionnels l'espace quoi en fait ça
fait quoi
il ya plein de trucs qui se poseront
regarde bien des objets donnent et
échangent dans l'auto ouais mais c'est
le truc que j'ai un nom à temps hugues
horaires j'ai un truc de ouf pas dans le
coin c'est pas bien l'ofac chasse alors
ça à [ __ ] le feu à la main non
j'éprouve pas le golf à la bravoure et
les [ __ ]
mais je m'en fous
de l'eau de l'eau alors à gros cubes
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient des liens aller
au monde et voilà les gens cydia la
foire de la première partie de notre
aventure sur man coiffe laird
alors n'hésite pas à laisser un petit
job dans un commentaire c'est a bien
aimé que sache si je fais un petit peu
plus de minecraft ou si vous aimez pas
du tout et en attendant je vous laisse
aller voir la deuxième partie en
cliquant sur la vidéo qui apparaît à
l'écran
à bientôt pour la secourir
c'est trop bien protégées trop stylé oh
la la
va-t'en va-t'en jva nord vous faire de
vos premières